[Musik]
denn heute in wales um mir auch ein bild
zu machen von der panzertruppe wo wir
wissen dass das notwendigkeiten gibt
auch der investitionen die wir in der
zukunft zu treffen haben die lehren der
vergangenheit nicht passiert sind aber
ich bekenne mich auch zur panzertruppe
auch zu den großartigen leistungen die
eine international immer gezeigt werden
aber es ist auch faktum dass wir
investieren müssen auch in diesem
bereich und deshalb bin ich heute hier
um eine lage auch ein lagebild zu
verschaffen und ich habe jetzt einmal
den eindruck dass das hochmotivierte
soldaten hier sind die hier am werk sind
hoch qualifiziert aber natürlich auch
mit entsprechenden wünschen einen
verteidigungsminister angetreten
also die ganze fahrt war voller fälle
sehr interessant und interessant auch
wie schnell das gerät desto ruhiger und
ich freue mich jetzt schon auf die
rückfahrt auch vielleicht kann man eine
sonder runde noch drehen weil das ist
auch nicht jeden tag davor dass man mit
einem panzer mitfahren darf ich war 13
jahre beim militär und ob es nicht
geschafft heute das erste mal als guter
tag